همم
الموسيقى في سلطنه عمان جزء اصيل في شخصيه
الانسان العماني طاهره جمال من اشهر عازفي
اله الكمان في السلطنه حيث بدات التعلم
على هذه الاله منذ نعومه اظافرها
بدات الموسيقى ونبل العمر 11 سنه
الوالد اعرض لي اني انا اقدم في
الفرقه السلطانيه
وكان هناك يعني يحتاجوا فرقه خاصه نسائيه
انا وخواتي قدمنا فيها هذه الفرقه والحمد
لله جهه الاختيار فيني انا وايضا همم خوات
عندي الاثنين
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
طاهره عضوه في فرقه دار الاوبرا السلطانيه
وشاركت في العديد من المحافل الدوليه
في مشاركات كمشاركه في افتتاحيه الملعب
المونديالي في قطر 2017
وايضا في مشاركه مع الفنان جهاد عقل
العازف الكمال العالمي في دار الاوبرا
السلطانيه
ارمي نظراتي كما انت اعمى انما نحن
العميان يتمثل بيت الشعر هذا في المؤلف
الموسيقي رائد الفارسي الذي فقد بصره لكن
بصيرته الفنيه اثرت المشهد الموسيقي في
سلطنه عمان
بدات منذ الطفوله المبكره باستخدام
الحالات عرفت
النوت الموسيقيه بطريقه طبعا برايل لتعلم
بها المكفوفين
ولقاعات والمقامات الموسيقيه كل هذا
ساعدني في صقر الموهبه الموسيقيه بعد ذلك
[موسيقى]
عبد الرحمن العصيمي من مسقط العربيه